تم نشر مقطع فيديو مدته 30 ثانية على نطاق واسع على
Twitter يظهر عضوة الكونغرس من نيويورك
ألكسندريا أوكاسيو كورتيز وهي ترقص على
لقطة على السطح بينما كانت طالبة في
جامعة بوسطن ، إنه جزء من عدة
دقائق لأفلام الثمانينيات مثل The
Breakfast Club ، وقد تم نشر المقطع في
اليوم  قبل أن يؤدي الكونجرس الجديد اليمين الدستورية
في محاولة واضحة لإحراج
برونكس البالغة من العمر 29 عامًا ولدت لاتينا ، وهي
أصغر امرأة منتخبة للكونغرس ، ومنذ ذلك الحين
تم حذف المنشور المجهول الذي وصف
نفسه بأنه اشتراكي
ديمقراطي وجاهل
وألهم رد فعل عنيف من  رد أولئك الذين
لم يروا شيئًا خاطئًا في أن طالبة جامعية
تستمتع أوكاسيو كورتيز
بتغريد مقطع فيديو جديد لنفسها وهي ترقص
في مكتبها ، كان المنشور الراقص
مجرد مثال آخر على جهد مستمر من
قبل منتقدي إل كاستيلو كورتيز
لتقليل اشتراكيتها الاشتراكية الفخورة.
الاشتراكية الديمقراطية لقد
أصبحت مانعًا
للمحافظين تقترح أن نتعامل مع
ذلك الذي نجلبه للاجتماع  الانتماء إلى
بلدنا الآن في فنزويلا ، هناك
أشخاص لا يستطيعون شراء الأحذية في نوفمبر / تشرين الثاني ،
كتب كاتب عمود في صحيفة واشنطن إكزامينر ذات الميول اليمينية
هذه
الصورة لأوكاسيو كورتيس وهي تسير في ممر مرتديًا
سترة تسعى على ما يبدو إلى إثارة
الشكوك حول ما إذا كانت تكافح
من الناحية الاقتصادية ، لم تكن أوكاسيو كورتيس خجولة
بشأن الرد على النشر ردًا على ذلك ، فإن
الظلام يكره الضوء ، ولهذا السبب قمت بضبط
هجوم بيري من
المحافظين بما في ذلك
الأسئلة المستمرة حول جذورها من الطبقة العاملة من
خلال استدعاء الجمهوريين المبتذلين
وإخبار أحد الملصقات أنك لم تفعل ذلك حتى  أعرف
من كنت قبل سبعة أشهر ،
فأنت لن تخبرني الآن في
إشارة إلى الجهد الطويل الذي
دافع عنه الرئيس ترامب في يوم من الأيام
لرسم الرئيس أوباما على أنه شخص غير أمريكي
وصلنا إليه هنا في واشنطن العاصمة لما أسميه بكل
حب يوم معسكر الكونجرس
صفر